With climbing, I don't think that it really matters how big you are.
If you're smaller, you can hold on longer...
...and your hands might be smaller so you can fit more fingers on holds.
I started climbing in Central Park when I was six years old.
Now I don't think I can live without it.
When you're close to the top of the climb you're trying to do,...
...your forearms usually feel like they're gonna explode...
...and they're gonna burst open and you feel like you have to let go.
But with climbing, you just can't let go.
I think that climbing is obviously a sport.
It's also like, advanced.
You sort of have to be able to like, flow up the wall...
...and come up with your own technique to get to the top.